en biélorussie pays voisins de la russie
ont continué de jouer au foot alors que
le monde du sport est à l'arrêt si la
moitié de la planète est confiné le
président alexandre loukachenko dénonce
une psychose et ce malgré 94 qui a
déclaré de corona virus sur le
territoire biélorusse
les restaurants sont toujours ouverts et
les supporters continuent donc d'aller
au stade écouter certains d'entre eux un
discours qui semble en décalage avec le
reste du monde
on doit aussi prendre les transports en
commun pour aller travailler ce n'est
pas grave il avait une grippe aviaire
avant par exemple il y a toujours eu
quelque chose rien à craindre
qui ne risque rien n'a rien nous irons
au stade tant que tu sors autorisée
notre président a déclaré que travailler
sur un tracteur guérir est tout le monde
donc on sera en bonne santé
on continue à vivre comme avant il n'y a
pas de peur depuis qu'on est arrivé au
stade on regarde le match